what's up guys it's Sam I'm talking to
you from the mountains of Utah and I'm
here to tell you that we have released
our second apparel drop of the year for
human good
please go on to human good Ellie calm
we've brought back some of your favorite
designs with a twist please check it out
without further ado enjoy the episode
what like you tell me oh my god what is
required for a group of ordinary
individuals to overcome a difficult
obstacle in order to answer that
question we created a team of nine
amateur chess players to face off with
one formidable foe hi my name is Dylan I
have about 8 to 9 years of experience in
chess each round one person will be made
the team captain everyone must work
together to help the team captain decide
what is the next best move as the game
progresses the time limits for each
round will get shorter can this team
figure out how to work together and
succeed
alright let's just go through like quick
introductions I guess can we decide to
move first and then do intros okay let's
do that
what does I mean the first move so I
guess it sets the pace in a way before I
always do that that's like classic no
that's what you want to do it that's
like okay I want to start the middle
teams looking pretty good I'm feeling
kind of nervous I really don't want to
lose the game if I move okay yeah I'm
Jenny easy remember my name is dawn it's
because I'm so odd I'm Sam I'm 19 years
old my name is Percy the king of the
bullets in California
what's up logo from Waynesville
Pennsylvania I'm from Nebraska my name
is Max I really like actually Simon it's
like a four he forgot me to introduce
myself so we have decided to move the
pawn from e2 to e4 alright so they moved
pawn to e4 which is pretty generic move
even though it is their first move I can
tell that that you have some experience
with chess I do note I don't know what
experience with chess they have I think
the Knights are something we want to
pull out right now
because they have a nice way of like
jumping around and attacking from the
angles yeah what if we move the knight
from b1 to c3 well I was thinking that
g1 night so that we could do a castle
move does everyone know what that is
when like all the pieces between the
rook and the King are empty and then you
like swap the places so that the king is
in G look for example and then the brook
will be an F and that's what I moved it
kind of corn it corners ourselves
automatically eight moves we're gonna
move the knight on b1 to c3 I wanted to
move the other ones so that we could do
the kingside castling honestly don't
know too much about chess strategy but
that was one of the things I
it's a good idea to try to do that I
feel like that maybe they're not as good
as some of the people I played in the
past but I'm still not completely sure
but it does give me a small boost of
confidence
I was try in the whole time I just
couldn't time right so Brandon 22 you
might be able to tell I'm in England
once I get a bit more confidence I
should be able to like get my challenge
tests skills out should we try to
capture the well I was think about the
deep on because then the bishop can move
around to d3 they move the day instead
of mm-hmm I think we're all in agreement
we're gonna move the pawn from BT to d4
I thought Brandon's like okay we're all
in agreement that so we're doing I'm not
too into taking this piece just because
I feel like if we do then they can bring
up their Bishop yeah we're just gonna
quit this route just kidding yeah we're
gonna go be cleared up before most rest
players usually play at the first but
that comes to mind just taking the peace
so I was surprised that they didn't do
that kind of move is Bishop yeah also
trying Castle so I think that's what
he's trying to do all right so we're
gonna move our time from g2 g3 the three
minutes is really hurting us right now
we need to like figure out a way to
communicate better with each other maybe
just saying the piece and like the move
like trying to be concise so that
everyone can you like agree or disagree
and we can discuss it further they're
kind of in my territory now
oh yeah I think Percy is someone I
really trust right now
and I think we need to listen to him a
little bit more I might have to take
control because I can already tell that
I am I'm probably the more skilled chess
player out of the group so he's starting
to plan different attacks that he can
make plus I think we want to unclutter
some of our stuff here because we he has
more control of the center of the board
f1 to h3 okay we should have seen that
coming
I feel like I'm gonna try to I guess
speak up more and get more involved it's
like we have some smart Minds in here
like we're not really utilizing those
right now this cuz we're being so
reactive would it potentially be better
to let him get to f1 and kill capture
with the King I think we should take the
bishop using a drumroll please
we're gonna move G I think Gary 1 to h3
now an awesome oh my gosh we capture the
first piece in the game
raise the roof I don't know I should
have been the castle I know I don't know
we're gonna do c12 e3 I feel like there
move kind of just destroyed their
position if I put it in a nice way
now I can just kind of a serve
domination over the game I hope this
isn't jeopardizing us but I'm gonna move
III to d2 I trust all gold the moles not
trust Sam the Leafs nobody seems to be
antagonistic yet which leaves me to
wonder if maybe I'm the one that people
don't like what if one of us is secretly
the other side and no the whole strategy
something is telling me the Percy is the
professional that we are playing against
I don't know why
Oh what he's gonna do is he's gonna use
his push-up to take the horse
Hey basically c3 to eat ooh yeah forgive
me you do that oh okay
so we got stuck into our first check 30
minutes is tough this is pretty makes
you think okay so we should just plan
ahead what do we want to do after that
and use this good call well actually
some what I'm thinking - is we can just
move the Queen here or do you want a
castle we go he'll be fine we can be
okay I did not know that okay now we
can't castle anymore so I'm jumping not
gonna be hearing from Sam anymore okay
okay I just want to say I don't have
anything against Sam I actually do like
it a lot
u1 to f1
I know we gotta get aggressive
you gotta get aggressive I wanted to be
one it's getting a little bit hot now I
don't know why I'm so confident talking
T to the camera but I can't talk to real
people the way he's playing he plays
like a troll I have no secret strategy
I'm not trolling them but if we move the
like the Kings from s1 to from F 1 2 G 2
and then so the people you'll take it
yes cool I like that yeah that's a good
idea
Charlie Charlie I feel like you might
take our clean and lose his I just I
feel like we gotta do force 1 - 2 D - D
- 2 C - D 1 to D for I'm definitely
feeling exhausted mentally d 4 to see
for this eg to d4 I don't think anyone's
playing off offense right now takes 3 to
ask for a 2 2 a for the pawn between 8
so we're in a pickle now that's not
looking good it's not looking good
I'll be honest and say I don't mean like
what's going on now so we're gonna go
into sprint mode we're gonna use the
last thing
when it hits game is over so 30 second
round okay go to it Fox 23 I felt like I
was being talked over in this round now
we're just like more amped up we could
be in first water this is going a lot
faster now it's pretty scary right now
so I'm really not sure how it's gonna go
the consensus is g3 he's retrieving we
should just take the pollen we're gonna
go d4 to c6 I want a personal Remax it
doing after this should be secret milk
I'm so sorry everybody
f4 to f5 it's okay oh my god right now
I'm just pretty relaxed
oh okay c6 ue5 safe for a fire the fat
lady singing
which was expected he's 16 years old I'm
putting it on putting my money on it I'm
saying like 20 watch it be like mid-20s
I said many switching back I want 86
final final answer
I'm Dillon I'm 13 I definitely thought
that you guys were gonna be worse so
it's pretty good pretty good
we had some amazing teammates who
definitely did have more experience than
others but they still let the people who
didn't have as much experience filter I
think for me the difficult thing was
gonna be to try and fit in and not talk
over people but then I felt like that
pretty much the reverse happened to me
you know I should probably be speaking
that's just because I don't know as much
as other people you know we're all human
beings we're all just you know trying to
help each other as much as we can guys
hey guys thanks for watching our video
don't forget to comment like and
subscribe jubilee media on all channels
don't forget to check out a pair of jump
to human good le com
we thank you we love you guys
and we'll see you next time
[Music]